>> RHODE: Android Developer Relations Office
Hours.
I'm Sparky from Munich, Germany and I'm joined
by my colleagues, Matt and Nick and Rich in
London, UK, Matt with Google TV.
>> BUTCHER: In [INDISTINCT] Burrito Mike's
this week.
So, we have...
>> HYNDMAN: Burrito [INDISTINCT] he's okay.
>> BUTCHER: We have Richard, the editor of
GeekYouUp.com
>> HYNDMAN: Yup.
My account is for...
>> BUTCHER: And the android account is Matt.
>> GAUNT: Hi.
>> HYNDMAN: My clothes today are brought to
you by The Dutch Android User Group.
We always do someone [INDISTINCT] and the
[INDISTINCT] GTALK [INDISTINCT] on the back.
Nick brought to us by Christmas I think.
>> BUTCHER: Yes, it's my Christmas jumper.
>> HYNDMAN: Christmas jumper.
And Matt by…
>> GAUNT: Nothing goes wrong with a man's
style with Google S [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: I was going to say Matt--Matt and
I are in--are in uniform today, so.
>> GAUNT: That's very good.
>> RHODE: All right.
>> BUTCHER: Someone had to be, Matthew.
Sorry Sparky we high jacked your beautiful
intro.
Carry on.
>> RHODE: No, no, no.
That was--that was far more interesting than
just having me say the usual thing.
But anyway, welcome everybody.
This is Android Developer Relations Office
Hours.
We're here to talk to you about anything related
to android application development.
Usual disclaimers apply which Rich will be
happy to deliver.
Basically, we generally restrict ourselves
to SDK related issues.
We don't talk about deep internals.
We don't talk about unreleased products or
our future plans.
But apart from that, we're happy to--we're
happy to basically, you know, see what you're
interested in, talk about what you're interested
in.
I see we're already joined in the Hangout
by several people.
We got some folks who have contributed questions
in the Moderator.
Hi, Andrew.
>> KELLY: Hey.
>> BUTCHER: And Andrew has a camera because
his girlfriend or wife isn't watching X-Factor
today.
>> KELLY: I can't see myself though.
>> BUTCHER: Oh.
>> HYNDMAN: Interesting.
>> KELLY: All right.
Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: I've always hope they put it in
Youtube live stream at the same time works
quite well, if you want to be 10 seconds behind
the rest of us.
Who's joined us on the far end side.
>> BUTCHER: It's Yossi.
>> HYNDMAN: Oh, Yossi.
There we go.
Hi.
>> RHODE: Yossi?
We have Yossi here.
>> HYNDMAN: Yossi.
>> RHODE: And so he got the memo about the
facial hair.
>> ELKRIEF: Yup, excellent.
I'm about to start a team.
>> BUTCHER: Join the club.
>> HYNDMAN: So we have Allan, Andy or Andrew
and Yossi all with us in the Hangout today.
>> RHODE: Okay.
>> HYNDMAN: Maybe [INDISTINCT] Good quality
camera for Elkrief.
>> RHODE: Yeah.
So, what's on your mind everybody?
Who has something that you'd like to share
with us or want to--have a question you want
to ask?
>> HYNDMAN: Well, I've got something I'd like
to share.
>> GAUNT: Go Rich, go.
>> HYNDMAN: It's just that we did for the
UK, specifically may have launched the 2,
3, and 1s that went passed recently.
But the Nexus 7, tablet of the year.
In fact--was it gadget of the year?
>> GAUNT: Gadget.
>> BUTCHER: Only one vote cast because it
beat out the Ipad 3 for tablet of year and
it won the overall, the big cache grade, the
gadget of the year.
>> HYNDMAN: Gadget of the year is The Nexus
7.
So we've been having a few little parties
around with Google Office here to celebrate
that.
Thank you very much to T3.
>> BUTCHER: Doesn't an old tablet look good?
>> GAUNT: Good indeed.
>> RHODE: I have to say, I mean it is a marvelous
device.
The Nexus 7 is my--basically my go to android
I mean I'll use my phone if I'm out and about
because I don't generally bring the tablet,
you know.
I mean I'll even bring my Nexus 7 with me
but it's in my bag, the phone is in my pocket.
But, you know, anywhere that I'm within range
of Wifi, the Nexus 7 is the device I want
to use.
>> GAUNT: Uh-hmm.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
>> BUTCHERS: Agreed.
So to developers out there, if you haven't
started looking at your apps and, you know,
if it's running well, if it's optimized for
the screen size and so on then, now is a good
time.
>> Rhode: Yeah.
Actually that reminds--that reminds me.
Isn't this week Tablet Week?
Shouldn't we be talking a whole lot about
tablets today?
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, we got a bit early last
week?
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, we probably recorded online.
>> GAUNT: Oh, yeah.
>> RHODE: I missed it.
I was...
>> ELKRIEF: I didn't call for a week and then
realized that it was Tablet Week.
>> HYNDMAN: Is that Leslie?
Is that you?
>> DREWERY: Hey, how are you doing?
>> HYNDMAN: He's muting.
And we'll say hello through sign language.
>> RHODE: Now, last week while you guys were
talking tablets, I was out there--I was out
there celebrating Deutschen Einheit.
It's a national holiday here in Germany last
week.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
We're jumping again on tablets.
Have you joined us today because you’ve
got some questions, Leslie, or you just come
along to hangout?
>> DREWERY: Just to hangout and see what's
happening.
>> HYNDMAN: All right, I see.
>> RHODE: Welcome to the Hangout.
I see that also Richard Thompson has just
jumped on.
Hello, Richard.
Do you have anything you want to talk about?
Maybe we'll give you a moment to get yourself
establish.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, man.
Give him a chance.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
So, yeah.
This is a point that anyone in the Hangout
can jump in and ask a question before we hit
the Moderator.
If anyone has anything they'd like to discuss.
>> GAUNT: Yossi is showing off some rather
a fancy [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: Oh, is that a serious tree?
>> ELKRIEF: I wouldn't like not to interrupt
you but I just wanted to show you our office
and also these.
>> HYNDMAN: Nice.
You've redecorated your entire office to be
android.
>> GAUNT: Excellent, you know.
>> BUTCHER: Hey, cool.
Nice sticks.
>> HYNDMAN: Good work, Yossi.
>> BUTCHER: Explicit.
I like it.
I like it a lot.
>> GAUNT: Interesting.
>> HYNDMAN: I'm sure that it enhances your
ability to do android development.
Nice talking.
>> BUTCHER: And just to catch up when we were
talking about tablets as well, I think the
reason we declared this Tablet Week is arbitrary
but it's also mostly to celebrate the new
quality guidelines we just released.
So it's a series of kind of checks you can
do to make sure your application is going
to look stellar on a--on larger devices.
So, hopefully you guys have all seen the blog
release on android-developers.blogspot.com
and seen the checklist and gone through that
and have a look at your apps and kind of seen
do they make use of white space, are they
going to scale, are they going to be available
on all devices which might have different
hardware configurations.
So it's kind of what catalyze this week's
kind of theme.
And Richard in the sidebar asks, "Will there
be Google TV quality guidelines?"
>> GAUNT: I mean that’s--so we've got a
lot of…
>> BUTCHER: I'm going to pass to Matt.
>> GAUNT: …documentation on Google TV design
guidelines over at developers.google.com/tv.
So, yeah, we've got a whole load of stuff
there about making it very cinematic and accounting
for [INDISTINCT] You're not--you're not really
going sort of--the interaction is more safer.
It's less of a one to one kind of thing where
people are usually using a personal device.
So, yeah, go check that out.
Lots of info there.
>> BUTCHER: So that's the checklist more of
kind of document or so?
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
It's much more kind of along the lines of
like the new design stuff that android went
through whereas it's more of--yeah, going
through the different sort of design patterns
you could follow and other aspects, so.
>> BUTCHER: Has anyone on the--in the hangout
had a chance to have a look at the Tablet
Quality Guidelines yet?
Any one?
>> ELKRIEF: Not yet.
>> SUTTON: Yeah, I've had a quick look through
them.
It looks cool.
It's…
>> BUTCHER: Do you suppose it's the kind of
thing you can--you can see yourself running
through?
>> SUTTON: Yeah, definitely.
The checklist is definitely something I'm
going to run through in every app because
it's one of those things, you make assumptions
about stuff.
You get caught up in the design and then you
sit there and I think, "Oh, I've forgotten
something fundamental."
So it's really useful to--so I see that checklist
is really useful to have.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
Especially when you're developing like you
are into like develop on device perhaps.
You might get into a single device mindset
where you, you know, going through debug cycles
trying to like get this piece of functionality
working and shift it.
And you sometimes don't think about the brackets
or stuff out there.
So I think having this simple checklist is
really helpful.
So have you guys seen it too?
And if you have any feedbacks or suggestions
then--to any android developers or one of
us and we can--we can suggest it.
Everyone is getting their [INDISTINCT] heads
on.
Look at this.
>> RHODE: Yeah.
That’s just the whole thing.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Cool.
So, are there any live questions in the Hangout
or any other news that people want to share
before we kind of jump into the Moderator?
>> GAUNT: Google TV is getting play.
It's getting native play.
>> BUTCHER: Yes.
Welcome to the club.
>> GAUNT: Which--yeah, I know.
It's been a long--long awaiting.
So, yeah, Google TV is finally getting native
play.
So you can finally rent and buy movies and
play it straight to Google TV which is fantastic.
We might grab on that.
>> BUTCHER: So, any changes for developers?
Anything, like any different internal docs
or whatever they can use now that they couldn't
before or anything like that?
>> GAUNT: No, I'm unaware.
We get subscription billing with the native
play.
So when that’s come in, that’s one which
I think a lot of people been wanting for a
little while.
>> BUTCHER: Cool.
>> GAUNT: So, yeah.
That's basically what's going on.
>> HYNDMAN: So you have it up and running
right now and that’s going to take…
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
For the moment we just got enough billing,
no subscriptions.
So that’s going to come out.
>> BUTCHER: That's inevitable.
Quite like last night, in fact.
Free trials, no subscription.
>> HYNDMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> BUTCHER: Everyone caught that?
If you have a subscription-based product with
the [INDISTINCT] without the free period it's
kind of getting used as hooks.
Oh, that seems--check down the sidebar.
>> RHODE: Yeah.
So Leslie asked a question in the sidebar.
He says, "How many companies are using the
accessibility framework and how does it sort
of stiffly refute all the good ones?"
>> HYNDMAN: Well, you know, we certainly have
recommended many times in the past that people
should at least put the content description
on all of their HTML text.
So it's just going to basically work but in
terms of using the entire accessibility framework,
I don't have a metric on that.
>> BUTCHER: No.
I have no stats.
I do know that Wolfram basically post a good
article on this lately.
So if anyone reads Grokking android block--blog,
it's great, a typical blog.
He recently did a very good post determining
how you would add accessibility towards your
apps, so.
Yeah.
[INDISTINCT]
>> DREWERY: Well, the actual question is who
uses it for anything other than the simple
content description?
I mean we use it quite extensively but the
solution to how powerful it really is to why
people are using it?
I think Richard here is in Joint Club this
month.
>> HYNDMAN: Excuse me.
I've got a bit of a cough going on.
>> BUTCHER: Which one, Joint Club UK?
>> HYNDMAN: Joint Club UK?
>> DREWERY: UK, yeah.
Yeah, let me get there.
I'll give you an insight to what we use in
the framework form, then you'll understand
the question in context to that.
>> HYNDMAN: It's a question of which context
will come three weeks later?
>> DREWERY: Yeah.
Well, remind me when you're there.
>> BUTCHER: And I'll see if I can dig out
anything relevant for you of that quite as
well, then I'll see you at Joint Club.
>> HYNDMAN: Joint Club UK?
I guess I will be there as well.
>> DREWERY: Yup.
>> HYNDMAN: Anyone else?
>> BANES: Hello.
I'm going to be there.
>> HYNDMAN: Hi Chris.
I see you pop in there and Matt as well.
>> GAUNT: Yup.
>> HYNDMAN: They'll be quite a few of us who'll
train from UK.
Okay.
So we jump into the Moderator then.
Well, Sparky, people hangout for the next
question.
>> RHODE: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: He's going to do it.
>> RHODE: First question is from Chris in
London.
Is there a reason why Google does not release
updates to new android versions for all interested
developers of Nexus 7 and Galaxy Nexus devices
right away outside along the [INDISTINCT]
cycle without having to route to the device,
etcetera.
Well, of course, there's a reason.
Oh, he says, "It would be--" He goes on to
say, "It would be convenient to have an option
of developer options where you app in to the
latest releases immediately rather than waiting
for your turn on the OTA," you know, sort
of phase rule out.
And he says, "Yes, it's only basically a developer
thing.
Not a lot of people would necessarily be using
it."
I actually think that's a great idea and I
like it so much that I opened the ticket in
our issue tracking systems saying we should
do this.
So, I don't know that you would save a lot
of time because we don't really waste a lot
of time between, you know.
And then, you've code freeze an OTA or perhaps
maybe the other way to turn around or just
say sometimes we have a scheduled [INDISTINCT]
deployment and we code right up into the last
possible minute.
But...
>> BUTCHER: Plus it seems to me we do a release
and we normally release the recovery images,
right?
The--so you can grab one of those and flash
yourself.
>> HYNDMAN: Yup.
>> BUTCHER: Or as soon as it hits OTA, I'm
pretty sure you can find the link to download
it.
>> HYNDMAN: People get the links and you don't
three devices to apply the official signs,
patches anyway.
>> RHODE: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: That's how we choose it.
Is Chris, was this you Chris Banes or is there
a different Chris in London?
>> BANES: Well, it was me.
>> HYNDMAN: Fair enough.
>> BUTCHER: What was the one Chris?
>> HYNDMAN: I said Chris in London.
There happens to be a Chris in here.
Couldn't be in the same room?
>> BANES: Right.
>> HYNDMAN: Actually, I'm not--and of course,
there's something like sometimes in the OTAs
if certain carriers require approval before
we apply patches to devices on the network.
>> BUTCHER: Yup, so a device that's developed
via straight from PLATO google.com and you
don't have a de--a carrier in between the
OTA service and to your device device.
>> HYNDMAN: This reference code is there for
EMEA.
>> RHODE: Right.
But it's--so, the gist of my--the ticket that
I opened was I suggested that basically people
who app in to this should be able to jump
to the head of the cue in the phase roll out
rather than, you know, waiting a few days.
That way if you have an app that, you know,
maybe breaks on the near release you can fix
it asap rather than having to wait a couple
of days free of term to get something wrong.
>> BANES: The trick of that is wouldn't everyone
just go, "Yeah, I'm a developer."
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: I'm just thinking that maybe it
has to be like in the pub site or some...
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: ...of that actually.
You have to be...
>> HYNDMAN: Right.
>> RHODE: Yeah, yeah, maybe enroll a device
through the developer console or something
like that.
>> BANES: Uh-huh.
Yeah, that's probably...
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT] through the play
console and you just grab the [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: If you're a developer, you're
going to be happy enough with that I'm sure.
Yeah.
So, all good ideas.
>> SUTTON: One of the--one of the ways I read
that is aren't they looking for a version
between releases?
>> HYNDMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> SUTTON: So, instead of waiting for a 4.10
to 4.11 or 4.1--4.0 to 4.1 without looking
for something between those two.
>> BUTCHER: Uh-hmm.
So that's what we did for the first time we
had Jelly bean, right?
We kind of had the developer preview.
It was out there for awhile so you could run
it in the emulator and you could get to know
the new API's before we went to shifting runs
and with the shifting devices and the final
full image, right?
So I think that seems to be the direction
we're going.
But I'd like to see us do it earlier if we
can but, you know, I don't make these decisions.
>> HYNDMAN: Excellent.
Okay.
Well, seeing as no one is shouting, let's
switch on to the next question in the Moderator.
We've got quite a few to get through today.
>> RHODE: Let's jump to the next question.
Mardon in Brayton, UK says, "I know it's still
a fair few amounts away but JAVA 8 is on the
horizon."
Okay.
Al gave a very good answer to that.
Al, do you want to--you want to reprise for
us want you said?
>> SUTTON: Sure.
Basically and Google is, you guys can't answer
forward looking statements about product development.
But one of the things with lambda expressions
is they need a change in the virtual machine
which came in in JAVA 7 and the Dalvik virtual
machine which android uses isn't equivalent
to a JAVA virtual machine.
So, you can't exactly say that version of
JAVA would be the same as the bytecode available
in the version of the Dalvik virtual machine.
So, there would probably be some work to implement
the functionality needed in the Dalvik virtual
machine and I see that that doesn't seem to
have started to being happened.
So, it might happen but its not going to be
for awhile yet would be pretty much is the
gist of the answer.
>> BUTCHER: Uh-hmm, interesting.
>> RHODE: Right.
And so the short version of Al's answer is
we're still in--we're still using JAVA 1.6
as our target environment and targeted API
level.
>> SUTTON: Yeah, pretty much.
>> BUTCHER: What else is in JAVA 8?
I mean, I miss my lambda so much.
I used to use lambdas a lot.
What else is in 8?
There's not a lot in 7, right?
There's the diamond operator and that's about
it.
>> SUTTON: There's a lot of stuff underneath
the hood in 7.
There's--one of the--its Dynamicinvoke I think
is the bi-code that got introduced in JAVA
7 which allows support for none JAVA languages
to be compiled.
That's...
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, like GVV and so on.
>> SUTTON: Exactly.
And it's that which is needed to get lambda
expressions sorted as well.
So I think a lot of the 7 was underneath the
hoods but...
>> BANES: It's also a--Its Project Coin so
that was the whole rebound that fits in the
language.
Just the thought you can use switch, a lot
of strings in switch statements and stuff
like that.
I think that was pushed back from 7 to 8.
>> BUTCHER: That's right.
>> BANES: But I can't remember the 8.
So, yeah.
>> BUTCHER: I was running that because a lot
of this stuff at lambda can--is often like
syntatical sugars.
It's often stuff that might not have low down
changes but you might...
>> HYNDMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> BUTCHER: ...give a go over [INDISTINCT]
or something.
But I know nothing about that stuff.
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
I mean, you can achieve pretty much the same
stuff with using a list of classes and interphases.
And that's the whole thing that lambda expressions
are being sort of touted as replacing.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: So there's no absolute need for
them but it's one of those things.
The less case you type, the happy your developers
are.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
Let's close maintain, let's boil the plate.
It's easier to read samples.
I think--I think lambda is a great [INDISTINCT]
mark but yeah, I'd like to see them.
>> HYNDMAN: Oh, no comment.
Okay.
>> BUTCHER: Well, I didn't know if it wasn't--if
and when they're coming but...
>> HYNDMAN: By December.
Anymore for anymore?
Anything in the chat?
Anything in the Google+ thread?
Is anyone through in that?
>> GAUNT: No.
I know we had it and now, I've lost--oh, got
it.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
Who's going to get that first?
>> GAUNT: Okay.
>> BUTCHER: You haven't joined like...
>> RHODE: While you're checking Google+, I'll
read the next--the next Moderator question.
Igo in Lviv, a great city where my previous
employer before at Google had an engineering
team, says, "Have you heard of android annotations
transfuse squares dagger links included?
These are annotation based compile-time code
generation controls.
What do we think of these?"
I mentioned a few more, RoboGuice, GreenDroid,
ORMLite.
I think they're all perfectly fine.
The problem basically is that every time you
introduce any kind of an obstruction layer
on top of an API, it has the potential to
simplify matters as long as you stay within
it but when you--when you start integrating
with the native other features of the system
sometimes it may not integrate quite so smoothly.
So, I think they're all good ideas and I think
it's worth, maybe worth a little bit of time
investigating and see if it works for your
used case.
I, you know, nothing against them.
It's just a matter of is the, you know, is
the benefit that you gain from it worth the
potential inconvenience of fitting it in together
with the rest of the system.
>> BUTCHER: Understood.
In agreement to Sparky, one of the thing I'll
add to that is the reason I quite like the
annotation based one is that there tend to
be a compile-time kind of stuff rather than
looking at runtime things.
Like looking at some of that RoboGuice for
example which offers great functionality but
you're going to take a hit at runtime using
the reflection and so on.
So, I think that's one of the advances why
I'd probably look into something like dagger
or, you know, android annotations.
>> HYNDMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> BUTCHER: Instead of the runtime ones just
because performance is such a consideration
on my book.
[INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: So...
>> BUTCHER: Any other comments?
>> BANES: What you said--Sparky mentioned
the ORMLite and I mean that's a runtime one
so that's runtime annotations as [INDISTINCT]
GreenDroid whereas that's compile-time but
it has more work in it.
So, I'm just--I'm not agreeing.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
My call on these things is they tend to be
awesome when you know how to use them.
Like once you--if you're the developer of
the project or something.
>> BANES: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: And you know it inside out, it's
like, "Look, how easy it is.
I could just like annotate this one annotation
and just a billion things."
Well, I find them quite like quite hard to
learn, quite hard to pick up unless you have
that whole surface area of knowledge about
the--of what it is.
And I find it can actually be hard to debug
sometimes if you don't know when stuff--especially
where there are tons of junctions.
If you don't know when stuff is getting crazy
and substantiating where it's coming from,
you know, if you have this great team and
someone is trying to come and debug an issue
then it can make it more complicated.
So, those are my only concerns about--around
these frameworks.
Like if you have just some, you know, not
standard but, you know, an android developer
who is coming in and want to have experience
and it could put him off but otherwise I think
that you have tons of benefits.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
>> RHODE: I'll also add just for the point,
just for the sake of adding it that GreenDroid
comes from Munich, Germany so go Munich.
>> HYNDMAN: Go Munich.
We've got another question at Google+ and
another question in the chat.
So, Leslie asked in the chat.
When will be able to add our own channels?
Maybe referring to--where's Leslie?
Are you referring to Google Play Store?
Yes, you can nod this way.
>> DREWERY: Well, the problem with Google
TV is that I very would like it to be able
to control my V+ box and stuff like that.
And I know the frequencies so I just want
to add them but without routing the device
that complicates the channel list.
>> GAUNT: Okay.
So...
>> BUTCHER: Over to Matt.
>> GAUNT: So at the moment you can't access
the channel list in Europe.
We're working to bring that over here because
over in the US it's a lot easier to get that
data for the channels that you have access
to.
When you start going internationally it depends
on which country you're in.
There's a couple weird little quirks.
Like people in Germany they can change the
order of the channels which they're not set
out to update here, et cetera.
So basically we're trying to find a nice reliable
way to actually give you access to that information.
But some of the stuff of you're talking about
just then, it remind of an API that we announced
at Google I/O called the immediate devices
API where you can then essentially pretend
it to be a set of top box or sort of create
a driver for an actual set of top box and
then you can start communicating between the
two.
So that's going to come with a later version
of Google TV which we don't have a date for
yet.
But hopefully it won't be too long.
So, yeah.
So, I've answered your question I hope.
>> DREWERY: Yeah, sort of.
What [INDISTINCT] take to get that upgrade
though?
>> GAUNT: I believe not much will take if
you will, I believe.
>> DREWERY: Okay.
>> HYNDMAN: Fingers crossed.
>> GAUNT: Yes.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: So in the--in the corner feed,
Yan is asking about a layout guide for NEXUS
7 in landscape and template one tablets in
landscape.
Well, like what would you want to know?
>> HYNDMAN: I was thinking use the same layout.
You can use the same for tablet [INDISTINCT]
and the Nexus 7.
>> BUTCHER: The answer is it depends.
It depends what you're trying to layout.
Like this is why we always say work through
your design because you kind of--there is
no magic law that says, this is the layout
that works on the phone that will work in
a 7 or work out on 7.
What works on 7 will work on 10.
There's nothing like that.
It really depends on your content.
So, what I always end up doing when I'm trying
to like say mock up screens for Android Design
in Action, you might start with the phone
layout and then like see what it looks like
on 10 and it might be too empty, it might
be too dense.
It really is like a kind of a gut feeling
thing.
You end up kind of trying on different size
layouts until you get the right amount and
the spacing, the right kind of density of
information.
So there's no magic law.
You kind of have to look at it and decide.
And in fact, if you look at the Nexus 7 at
the system master sheet where some of them
use the UI which switch shift on the phone
and some of them use the tablet UI.
So, people application for example uses a
tablet based on UI and it, you know, use this
basically nicely without too confusing and
so on.
But some of the applications like Google Play
Music for example who uses the frame UI.
It's a decision made by each kind of an application
depending on the information they're trying
to show and just how well it works in that
given amount of space.
So there is no answer to this.
It's try and have a look to see if it works.
If not, you might need to hint things, you
might need to change something, you might
need to add more space, bigger text sizes
and like that.
So there's no hard and fast rule.
>> HYNDMAN: And the Nexus 7 falls into the
SW600dp bucket in the layouts as well.
So you're going to have your--in a 10-inch
tablet you can put in the SW720s, your Nexus
7 and SW600s.
And if you want the same layouts you can just
get rid of the shortest width 720 folder and
you just pick up size that says the 7-inch.
But you can very easily distinguish between
a seven-inch and ten-inch tablets and decide
what goes in each one just by testing it and
what's best.
>> SUTTON: I find it quite interesting as
well that the Nexus 7 originally the launcher
was locked in portrait mode.
And the latest release of Jelly Bean which
is out and about now allows you to do the
wonderful thing of having the launcher in
landscape as well.
So, I guess it's--it really is just...
>> BUTCHER: [MAKES NOISE]
>> SUTTON: Yup, that's it.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: I can do it on mine too.
>> HYNDMAN: ...just a matter of...
>> RHODE: It's just wanting to get it right.
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
So, it's just goes to show that there's a
lot of experimentation that you need to do
before you get things that you enjoy.
>> GAUNT: Yes.
>> RHODE: One thing that I've noticed recently
is I've been a little bit surprise that even
now, like we we're what, a year and a half
after Honeycomb?
There's a lot of apps especially games adjust.
Like even on a 10-inch tablet they just scale
up the phone UI and I think it's--in particular
for games it's more of a problem even than
some of the others.
I mean yes, they don't have a problem with,
you know, huge amounts of white space because
they're using OpenGL and scaling everything
proportionally.
But some of these games used gestures where
the amount that you travel on screen matters
and it can actually be significantly harder
to play the same game on a tablet because
you have to move your finger that much faster
in the same amount or that much further in
the same amount of time.
I’m thinking of games like Flight Control
or Flick Golf or something like that where
you train your, you know, you train your muscles
to work faster on a certain screen size and
then, you switch to a tablet and all of a
sudden everything is different.
And, you know, there's a real fatigue factor
that comes in to dragging those airplanes
all the way across in your screen.
>> SUTTON: It's interesting…
>> RHODE: So…
>> SUTTON: …that in the Tablet App Quality
Checklist sort of three or four the points
all go across the same thing you're just saying--been
saying, Sparky.
By using fonts and touch targets and assets
designed for that kind of size of screen so
hopefully it's something that the checklist
will hope reinforce with people.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
The good news is it can be a bit scary because
you think about this continuous sort of like
range of device sizes out there.
So, if you think about, "Oh, do I have to
allocate my layouts and make a layout that
works great on a, you know, a 4-inch phone,
a 5-inch phone, a 7-inch tablet and 8.9-inch
tablet.
The good thing about this is like there's
actually kind of a discrete number of switching
points at the moment.
We kind of see a lot of the stuff kind of
setting around four, seven, and ten.
It's kind of like come in places and the variations
around that are not so huge that you can use
a layout that works on like a seven-inch tablet
will probably work on someone's--on an eight-inch
tablet.
And so the way system works, if you use these
SW qualifiers for your layouts then it will
get pick up by the kind of the one slightly
larger as well.
So, it's not actually tons and tons of stuff
you do but just by providing slightly say--like
you said, bigger touch targets or slightly
bigger font sizes for example in like a seven-inch
tablet can make all the difference.
>> RHODE: Right.
And then another bit of tablet wisdom is that,
you know, so you're going back to the game
model, you don't have to necessarily scale
up your game to fill the whole screen.
You can have a fragment that varies it size
only a certain amount and then on the larger
screens just put more or less ancillary information
around--on the sides of it.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: Indeed.
We asked that one.
>> HYNDMAN: Who watched last night's Android
Live in Action which covers runtime.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
This is--this is the topic we covered yesterday
on that.
>> HYNDMAN: It's a whole half hour of that.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, yeah.
Giving a few techniques you can use to design
around this issue.
>> SUTTON: And it's--it was great that you
guys were looking at the I/O app which is
completely open source.
So you can just go in and grab the source
and copy whatever it's been done in that wonderful
software.
>> HYNDMAN: Yes, the new templates in the--the
android templates and that we use.
We create new project and clips rather than
getting into that.
>> BUTCHER: And Jan has joined us.
Hello.
Did that answer your question?
You're muted.
>> HYNDMAN: Is John talking or not?
>> BUTCHER: You're not talking.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
>> SOUZA: Yes, thank you.
>> HYNDMAN: Excellent.
You got into Hangout.
>> BUTCHER: Oh, well, thanks for joining us.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
Let's jump to the next one in the Moderator.
>> RHODE: All right then.
Yeah, there's--this is Yan's question in the
Moderator.
Yan, do you want me to ask your question?
I don't see...
>> GAUNT: [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: Okay.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT] lip sync.
>> RHODE: Right.
Okay.
So, right--Yan in the Hangout is asking, is
it a good approach to in-app purchasing to
remove ads versus, you know, within 1ABK versus
maintaining two applications, one with and
one without?
And I said it's a great idea to use an application
purchasing to remove ads.
>> BUTCHER: Uh-hmm.
>> RHODE: Then--and provided this developer
that android link for a little more information.
You know, since you can make it a managed
purchase, you can query the server anytime
and find out whether to--whether that user
has purchased the right to have the whatever
unlocked ad free premium pro-version of the
app.
There's--I think there's significant benefit
in not maintaining two different APKs.
You--to a certain extent, you're exposing
your app potentially to a little more risk
in that, you know, the code that queries the
license server or the, in-app purchasing server
is another attached surface, but I don't really
don't think it opens you up anymore than just
having a separate pro-version of the APK where
somebody can just, you know, redistribute
that.
So, I think that the--without a lot of extra
headaches involved, you can really save yourself
some trouble just by not maintaining two different
APKs for the same application.
>> Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: And two other points to add to
that.
Is a--sorry Chris, is suppose to [INDISTINCT]
so it goes out their jumping out to, you know
hit, I want to get [INDISTINCT] and you have
to then install a new app.
I was like "Wait, what?
Now I have two apps installed, so I have to
uninstall an app and also any settings or
configurations I may have done it gets carried
over, since it's the same application.
I don't have to configure anything again.
So, that's a lot smoother and secondly, I'd
say you that all your reviews and comments
will be centralized in one place.
And somewhat a good or bad thing, you can
go find that people who [INDISTINCT] for [INDISTINCT]
on your rating, because they paid money for
it.
They tend to like, justify that sales I think.
Maybe that's just my idea.
And but--yeah, I think having them all in
one place is probably a better thing.
>> SUTTON: That's all so quite interesting.
>> KELLY: Yeah, yeah, the...
>> SUTTON: I'm sorry, Chris, good for me.
>> BANES: No, I'm just saying, you know, I
did this for FriendCaster.
I had made this before in-app purchasing was
invaluable so two separate ones the free and
the pro.
And I use to spend a good 10 to 15% of my
time merging code across because you'd have
to--you'd have to do it in one code device
then copy it across.
And what you find is you're trying--you wouldn't
copy it across, correct?
So, you have to spend time fixing lamps and
stuff.
So, in the end [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: More library projects.
>> BANES: Pardon?
>> BUTCHER: Was that before library projects
or...
>> BANES: Yeah.
So, once library projects come out which then
I can stop moving color code into that and
then sharing it.
It just--it still took time and so, yeah,
and I've always go now with one APK.
And other thing is also is that--because it
will look--because you have the free versions
in your listening, people will be more inclined
to download it because it's not paid app.
>> HYNDMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> BANES: So, and then they can then do the
in-app purchase where if they want to so in
other words they're not minor.
>> SUTTON: Yeah, that was one of the interesting
things from IO is that there was some discussion
around monetizing app and all of the data
seem to point to having an in-app purchase
as being a better way and a more consistent
way of getting users to buy your app and it
tends to result in more purchases than trying
to get them to download a separate APK and
pay for that separately.
>> BUTCHER: Just Devil's Advocate as a slight
[INDISTINCT].
I'd say some people just hate in-app purchases.
You'll see comments in the market saying "They're
trying to nickel and dime for everything,
blah, blah, blah," and some people are just
much happier paying one app price up front.
I'm not not saying this is many users or most
users, so some people just don't like that
and the second point is having a paid out,
let's you put this way in some kind of like
sales and promotions, so for example...
>> HYNDMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> BUTCHER: ...our recent 25 billion promotion
was--where were put a bunch of applications
on sale like if you only had a free application
then, that would have been available to use.
So, I'm not saying these great reasons and
perhaps you might have both available.
So, you know, a free version with in-app to
attach [INDISTINCT] first or like a premium
version or whatever that is just like all
in-app purchases already included in the different
costs for example for those people who just
really hate it.
It's up you, you know, it depends on who you're
going for and what the market is and so, but.
>> SUTTON: Yeah, I think there's a lot of
work that needs to be done in terms of user
experience on the developer side because I
think it was Yahani point--pointed out an
application that basically was a free application
but the moment you run it, it said buy coins
and you couldn't do anything without making
an in-app purchase and that's a straight turn
off for users, it's going to be a bit more
subtle.
>> RHODE: Oh, I hate those.
>> SUTTON: It's the easiest.
One wasn't the only that you found was there?
I guess there are few out there, but it has
to sparky response and people just turn off
straight away, say trying to force people
down in an in-app purchase is a way around
paid app.
It's seems to be--yeah, more of a quick way
to annoy the user than to get sales.
>> BUTCHER: Crappy thing to do.
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> RHODE: So, the applications, let's say,
you get ten moves and if you send us a couple
of bucks, we'll give you another hundred.
I hate those, I hate those.
But the apps that say, you know, you can--you
can unlock the first 10 levels of this puzzle
game for free and then, you know, pay us a
couple of bucks and we'll give you the next
hundred levels and you can, you know, you
can play as much as little as you like.
We're not metering your play, we're just giving
you access to the whole thing, those I love.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, I think the mail, are one
of the coolest ones I've seen is the timed
office.
It's like a wind up night which gives you--lets
you play for your first 10 levels or something
like that and then it says, "Hey, one time
early offer, unlock the rest of this game
for this one price won't be offering again
kind of thing."
I mean that kind of taps into the human psyche
wanting a bargain right like you can get,
okay?
You're just one chance to play.
I thought that was pretty clever and I think
[INDISTINCT] just came on to the show on US
and said that one item was the bulk of their
revenue, I think.
>> HYNDMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> GAUNT: Uh-hmm.
>> BANES: Just the app, App Store as well?
>> KELLY: The other good thing...
>> BANES: Sorry, mate.
>> KELLY: Sorry.
I was just going to say quickly, the other
good thing about the in-app billing stuff
is that you make a purchase on one device
that alone market for all your other devices
as well.
>> BUTCHER: Oh, yeah.
>> RHODE: Right.
Well, I hadn't even thought of that.
I mean, talking about saving your download
trouble.
>> GAUNT: Yeah, you can have it everywhere
and you're going to have the free install
everywhere and then.
>> BUTCHER: Free install, yeah, times end.
>> And then you have to go back and reinstall
the new one, yeah.
>> BUTCHER: The clip.
Chris, so you're saying as well?
>> BANES: I'm saying as with the App Store--I
mean, I can't even say it.
But the App Store on iOS you can't actually
see what the in-app purchase are.
When you download something was our comment
on Google Play.
I could be wrong, but none.
>> GAUNT: Interesting.
>> HYNDMAN: You can see it is needs the in-app
billing permission, so you can go with out
the in-app payments in there somewhere.
>> BANES: Right, but if you download and see
there's an in-app purchase for playing rest
of game or something then you know it's going
to be dodging.
>> HYNDMAN: Play whole of game.
>> BANES: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: But there's a lot--there's a lot
of things around that because one other things
I've seen done in the iOS Store is some of
the in-app purchases makes no sense until
you start using the application itself, like
I think there's an application that converts
photos into cartoons and everything is like
the splat in-app purchase and the glam in-app
purchase which it--you kind to sit there and
I'm thinking, do I really need to buy this
to put the word glam on screen and it's--it--it's
kind of a double edge sword.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, I'm not sure if I see the
value on that.
>> RHODE: I think it's the value in it if
you make it cheap enough.
I mean...
>> BUTCHER: I know, and [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: ...it's below the threshold where
I'll just say, oh, what the heck, from one
photo, I am willing to spend ten cents, click.
>> BUTCHER: No, no, I can see the value.
I don't see the value in listing them up front
when it's completely out of context.
>. RHODE: Okay, sorry.
>> BUTCHER: Well one of the ones that I quite
like is a German game [INDISTINCT] which we
know who has the ads and this little X next
to it to dismiss them and that launches the
in-app purchase switches an interesting location.
I think we've done that one to [INDISTINCT].
>> BANES: Lots of [INDISTINCT] in-app purchase.
>> RHODE: Does anyone here live in the Hangout
want to bring up something of interest to
them before we go back to the Moderator or
were there questions in the Google+ stream
that we haven't gotten to yet?
>> HYNDMAN: There's one [INDISTINCT] today.
>> SOUZA: Right, excuse me?
>> SUTTON: There's one for Matt in the comments
of the Google+ page.
>. HYNDMAN: We again got another question
here.
>> BUTCHER: Let's take a live question.
>> SOUZA: Yes.
It's not a question but feature request.
I like you to include the feature graphic
on my [INDISTINCT].
>> BUTCHER: Sorry, say that again, I missed
that.
>> SOUZA: Feature graphic.
>> BUTCHER: Uh-huh.
>> SOUZA: On my application, my [INDISTINCT]
because...
>> BUTCHER: You would like to localize the
feature behind, correct?
>> SOUZA: Yes.
This one...
>> BUTCHER: Just the same or one of this [INDISTINCT]
is on the--it's on the team's list of stuff
to do.
>> HYNDMAN: It is crazy right now, right?
You can localize all the descriptions but
if you want to localize the great big graphic
that everyone sees...
>> BUTCHER: And screen shots, uh-hmm.
>> HYNDMAN: ...and screen shots and all that
stuffs, yes.
You must list things and target them into
countries so that's...
>> BUTCHER: It's very, very much on the radar,
it's just when it gets shift.
>> HYNDMAN: Should we?
>> BUTCHER: We hear you, we hear you.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
>> BUTCHER: Sorry, did you want to read the
question tonight in the comments, shall I
read it?
>> GAUNT: Yeah, Go for it.
>> BUTCHER: So, I was trying to get that comic
app with in-app billing working on Google
TV.
They have to send you box, I always get stuck
at the billing process or froze in purchase
up to 30 seconds this application stops responding.
>> GAUNT: So, I've actually replied to the
stock over flow question with a blunt face.
>> BUTCHER: It's not.
>> GAUNT: So, essentially, there's--because
we don't support subscription billing, the
dungeons and subscriptions sample doesn't
work as is.
Needs a little bit of tweaking to change the
trial version number as well as some of the
extra variables that you add in, so payment
type, you don't do that or otherwise API starts
having some problems.
So, you need to that and plus when I start
doing this, I have a couple of issues that's
just the Google Play service and making it
work.
So I had to leave it for a little while.
Which I admit is a bit of a bore thing but
I do essentially have one bit of code left
for it before they came back and then it just
started working as it should do.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, that happens to me too.
>> GAUNT: I think it was just the propagating
the items that you are adding to Google Play
and make sure that it works and authenticate
et cera.
So check out the blog post , go through all
of that, check that are working with your
items and then hopefully you should be able
to figure out what's going wrong.
>> HYNDMAN: Yup.
All the standard things apply.
Don't test it with the same account you uploaded
the app to Play Store you can't buy them for
yourselves.
There's a list of five things you each need
to check when you're testing in acronym in
the testing--acronym document.
>> HYNDMAN: Yup.
Documentation is ridiculously useful.
So, yeah, still do check that.
It's just the sample which needs some differences
which what my blog post is focusing on.
>> BUTCHER: Okay.
And there's a question in there G+ as well.
Robert is asking why in the 4.12 update for
seven-inch tablets, why search bar angled
on the landscape put an option on portrait?
None of us here know the answer.
I'm going to speculate here that it's a UX
decision.
That in landscape you have so much less vertical
space that you don't really want as many angled
items.
I'm going to guess that that being the reason
but I don't know for sure.
>> SUTTON: I don't believe it's actually a
widget in landscape mode.
>> BUTCHER: No, it's part of the home screen,
right?
>> SUTTON: Yeah, where as in portrait mode
it's actually a widget that seems to be used.
>> BUTCHER: Is it?
I don't think it is.
I think it's--you can't pick it up or anything.
>> HYNDMAN: You can't regardless...
>> GAUNT: Right.
>> HYNDMAN: ...I'm slightly confused by this
question.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> GAUNT: We're all just staring at the seven-inch
tablet.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT] can anyone replicate
this?
>> BUTCHER: So, I think it's--I don't think
it's a widget.
I think it's part of the home screen.
>> HYNDMAN: I think it's part of the launcher,
yeah.
>> RHODE: Right.
I think so too.
I mean, I don't think it's like when you drag
a new widget onto the screen.
It seems to me like that search box is out
of the accessible space.
>> HYNDMAN: Can you move it right on yours?
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
And when you drag an icon around here, it
disappears to make room for the app info and
the delete button whatnot.
I don't actually think its part of the home
screen like work spaces.
Where I think it's kind of decoration around
it.
>> SUTTON: Yeah, I can't actually drag mine
around.
It's just a bit confusing.
Instead it's anchored in landscape but optional
in portrait.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I have--I can replicate that.
>> BUTCHER: I read that as it's kind of always
there in portrait.
But when you go to landscape you just have
to Google now and the--and the voice action,
it's a voice search buttons, right?
>> SUTTON: Right.
Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: It would be neat if you had a
vertical text bar.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, exactly.
>> HYNDMAN: I think that's about.
Anyway.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
So, yeah.
So, basically I'm saying.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, you wouldn't ever have like
a vertical search box because that would look
crazy.
I probably wouldn't.
And so I'll like postulate that they didn't
want to have another reserved error space
in already limited amount of room when you're
in landscape would be my guess.
>> HYNDMAN: Well, I concur.
Excellent.
>> RHODE: I think that's a really good guess.
>> BUTCHER: Why thank you.
>> RHODE: Since you mentioned Google now,
this is just kind of a random, what it occurs
to me.
I'm curious to know, who here brings up Google
now by accident more often than on purpose.
Because I know I…
>> BANES: [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: Interesting.
All right.
>> RHODE: Going back to that flight control
again.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: Making those little airplanes around
the screen.
>> Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: I can suggest one solution.
If you have that problem with your Nexus 7
put it in a case because it's really hard
to bring up the tall ones to the case.
>> BANES: Is that the official Google answer?
>> HYNDMAN: Of course it is, Chris.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT] answer.
>> SUTTON: That's one of the downside of those
cheap third party cases.
You get the official aces while then it leaves
you enough screen space to get the swipe from
the problem working.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT] and that it certainly
doesn't.
>> SUTTON: Yeah, this was 25 [INDISTINCT]
from PC World.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT] magnet in it though.
>> SUTTION: Nope.
You pay 25 [INDISTINCT] you…
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: …you don't even get the close
magnet.
>> BANES: I've got a smart cover [INDISTINCT]
or it's like a natural--it flaps over and
stuff.
It's pretty good.
It's like a ten ounce.
>> GAUNT: I've got one of those as well for
my Samsung Tablet.
>> BUTCHER: Well, for the--for the Nexus 7
I guess.
>> BANES: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: I think my next purchase from Amazon
is going to be some [INDISTINCT] tape and
a magnet.
How are we getting on the Moderator questions?
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, how are we getting on Moderator
question?
>> RHODE: I'm taking a look.
>> BUTCHER: We've got fifteen minutes left.
>> RHODE: Okay.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: Andre in Czech Republic wants to
know, is there a way how to correctly detect
if a tablet has a mobile, it's like [INDISTINCT]
3G interface.
I need to hide or display some features based
on that.
Feature telephony and connectivity manager,
get all network info aren't reliable enough.
I don't know.
I think I don't--I think I don't have the
best answer to that one.
>> SUTTON: It was--I was kind of confused
because he is saying feature telephony isn't
reliable enough.
And I was wondering whether he is already
using PackageManager.system feature to detect
whether it's on the device.
>> RHODE: I'm wondering if maybe he just means
it's not precise enough.
>> SUTTON: Right.
Because there are some features [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: We've got an extra comments in
the bottom here.
Thanks for your responses but unfortunately
there are some tablets that don't report feature
telephony as one of the system features.
I imagine things like…
>> SUTTON: Wifi only devices.
>> HYNDMAN: …out of the--no the Galaxy Tab
10.1 may have 3G but no telephony because
it doesn't--you can't make phone calls.
>> SUTTON: Right.
But the feature should be as said that the
device has a telephony radio with data communication
support.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: Which to me would indicate it should
be present…
>> ELKRIEF: [INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: …if just got a data modem on
it.
It doesn't necessarily need to have a voice
codec as well to handle calls.
>> HYNDMAN: Interesting.
Yeah, I can't remember.
If the input requires telephony in the manifest
whether it would appear for a 3G Tab or not,
I thought it didn't.
>> RHODE: There you go.
I do think maybe there's potential in this
TelephonyManager get network type, which should
tell you like exactly what kind of radio you're
talking to at the moment.
>> BUTCHER: But that's what's on at the moment,
not what's available, right?
>> GAUNT: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: Lastly saying, querying the SIM
is a good way to go.
>> RHODE: Querying the SIM?
>> HYNDMAN: Which class would you use to do
that [INDISTINCT] we'll give him--I'll read
out the URL.
>> DREWERY: Yeah.
You could actually use some tools libraries
to do it.
We had this problem in HTC.
Where if you got a SIM that supports 2G but
doesn't support 3G it caused a bit of confusion,
we had to actually query directly.
Our HTC now could find the--on HTC devices
the custom API that we used.
>> SUTTON: Well, but there is in TelephonyManager
it gets subscriber ID which is supposed to
return an IMSI number.
I guess--I would guess, if there's no 3G or
no telephony component then you wouldn't get
an IMSI back.
I think you get nulled back in that situation.
>> ELKRIEF: It's interesting.
I've seen a custom ROMS that do return IMSI
or even fake data just to pass some test on
the TelephonyManager.
So I'll try to do some--try to catch over
there enough on false data.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
I think I know we've kind of had a similar
question last week.
It comes down to why you're trying to do that
exactly like--I guess the main thing you want
to do is like work out.
Do you have a data connection, right?
Which you can use to get connectivity [INDISTINCT]
but it's connected.
It's pretty much on your major check.
>> HYNDMAN: I was thinking [INDISTINCT] had
also a setting which said--let's say it was
ooVoo and it wanted to allow calls over 3G.
You wouldn't want that setting there at all
if you have 3G device.
But you do have 3G, one that particular if
you have or not.
It could make sense to have a [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: I know, I exceptionally use it.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, it's up to you because [INDISTINCT]
in the 3G but [INDISTINCT] I think its 3G
and Wifi.
>> GAUNT: But you only want to show the option
when you have 3G as an actual option to take
away [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: But you can [INDISTINCT] if you're
on cellular or you're on Wifi [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: No, no, just 3G.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> BANES: [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: If you're on it at the time [INDISTINCT]
>> DREWERY: You forgot one thing guys.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
>> DREWERY: The same competence of certain
[INDISTINCT] in this country will allow you
to connect to the 3G network, but not use
it.
I won't mention any names as a dropping sales,
so what that means is that you might have
a 3G subscription but it will allow you to
connect to 3G matrix saying you got 3G but
you can't actually send any data up.
>> SUTTON: That's also another issue which
makes the whole thing a bit an unreliable
is the use of Mifi devices.
So I've got a Wifi tablet and I'm connecting
it to my portable hot spot on the phone in
my pocket.
The tablet it thinks it's got a Wifi connection
but the actual end connection is a 3G cellular
on the other one.
That's how I got around the [INDISTINCT] as
an original restriction of only allowing streaming
on Wifi which is to use a Mifi device.
Do some tethering between the tablet and the
Mifi device and then you get around any restrictions.
Although it may be possible it's not a good
thing to rely on looping [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I can see where [INDISTINCT] it would be nice
for those [INDISTINCT] I would still use [INDISTINCT]
correctly then so be it.
But you want to know whether the [INDISTINCT]
in there you want to know if the hardware
supports that capability then I would go to
the feature telephony.
It's got to be [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: As oppose to its quality of users
experience issue.
Say maybe you know if you can't pull one megabit
you don't want to offer video or something
like that just do a little performance test
at run time.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
You can do--when you're connected you know
what network you're connected on.
It's just you just don't know which networks
are necessarily available to you.
>> SUTTON: The performance test would be the
best way to go definitely because of Wifi
situations like IO.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
And definitely I think about not making a
setting as well.
Think about just doing a test and you get
a warning.
>> HYNDMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> BUTCHER: Like saying you know signal strength
looks weak.
You sure you want to do a video call or whatever
it might be.
>> ELKRIEF: Yeah, that's what we do.
>> BUTCHER: Just making a setting isn't always
the answers.
>> HYNDMAN: Read Reto's blog post on magic
boxes as well.
What's the problem with network?
You probably don't get sub type.
Maybe you have to be connected to that network
at the time, you know.
He--what do we have here?
He has said he's using network [INDISTINCT].
Have we got anymore in the Moderator?
>> SPARKY: We do.
And we have a couple more.
>> SUTTON: And questions from Andrew Kelly
in there
>> SPARKY: Andrew Kelly, yes indeed.
About ViewPager, a list of pages, Andrew do
you want to ask?
>> KELLY: Yes, since we are--I've got an app
that I'm writing for a client at the moment
and I got a listview that goes into a ViewPager
kind of mode when they want it drilled down
into the details of the list.
And so, in the listview I want to show all
the items available.
>> SUTTON: Uh-hmm.
>> KELLY: But in this the detail mode running
on the ViewPager, I want to skip over items
that don't have any further details.
And so, I'm just trying to work out if there's
a way of skipping with the fourth element
of the array without actually having to create
a new array with that fourth element missing.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, well that's in the Adapter,
right?
In the get size and method.
So, these...
>> KELLY: Yeah, so I got my get count reduced--returns
a fewer number of--yeah, a lower value based
on how many rows there are.
The get item still gets called for the place
holders that I don't want to--the ones I want
to skip over, so if I want to skip over element
number four.
>> Uh-hmm.
>> KELLY: Element, you know, get out and still
gets called for element four.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, you know.
You're always going to get passed in the time
being increasing position numbers, but I think
you're going to have to maintain your own
mapping from position to the real item index
in your--in your data.
>> KELLY: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: Correct.
>> BANES: [INDISTINCT] it sound like you need
to--you get them and you just need to--each
time iterate from the start and can't until
you find x numbers of items which don't have
a flat board do [INDISTINCT] whatever.
>> Yeah.
>> KELLY: Yeah, I 'm just trying to avoid
the constant to be going looping with the
array...
>> BANES: Yeah.
>> KELLY: ...again and again and again to
where that [INDISTINCT] was.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT] trying to.
Yeah, can you just do that once?
Can you do so the first fast item is index
one, second item is index four, the third
item is index five or...
>> ELKRIEF: No, maybe he has a HashMap.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> ELKRIEF: Only in one second, you have all
the index's made through the items with the
details.
And then, when you use the get item than you'll
just need to verify that you have the index
on your attachment or some sort.
>> SUTTON: Well you could even--if you put--put
it into a HashMap, you could then get the
entry set back and iterate over the entry
set.
>> KELLY: Yeah, some adjustments.
That's a good idea.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, you just run through once.
Are we talking about an enormous list here
though?
Is this something you need to be relaxed?
>> KELLY: No, at 20 at most so...
>> HYNDMAN: You know, I just run through it
to be honest.
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
They said the possibility for some of the
items to change.
So, could item number two be populated then
later down the line then item two could not
be populated?
>> KELLY: Not with out going all the way back
out and all the way back in through the original
on a summary list.
>> BUTCHER: It's now [INDISTINCT] go take
a hit and did it once...
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
>> BUTCHER: ...and have this simple of HashMap
or something.
>> KEELY: Yeah, and that was.
>> BANES: It's currently [INDISTINCT]
>> KELLY: And I thought it might be having
some sort of--is enabled kind of true or false,
kind of method that I could just call for
the ones that I want to skip over.
>> HYNDMAN: No.
I mean, you have full control of your Adapter,
it wouldn't...
>> KELLY: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: ...pass the Adapter then ignore
it.
It would--self service, sorry.
>> KELLY: That's right.
>> BUTCHER: Well, you can extend ViewPager
and make your own implementation in that...
>> HYNDMAN: Ignoring the item in ViewPager.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> Sends the bytes and sends it.
>> RHODE: Yeah.
The reason that I pointed to the Sherlock
demo that's out there on code.google.com is
because the ViewPager implementation on that
little sample app basically it, you know although
ViewPager sequential, it basically just pokes
a random access value into the tab manager.
And you see--because it's mashing up ViewPager
in tabs together.
And so it's kind of a way to jump from your
sequential access of the ViewPager into the
random access, and all you have to do is intervene
at that point to tell it which you know, page
or tab to show.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, you could do it so that
when you go to item number four, it will also
scroll down.
You'd scroll to four and then it would automatically
just move onwards because it's an empty item.
Basically, would know they've gone past item
four.
This page is intentionally left blank, something.
No, but I think...
>> BUTCHER: No, don't do that.
>> HYNDMAN: No.
[INDISTINCT] I would definitely go with what
you said before.
>> BUTCHER: Five minutes left.
>> HYNDMAN: We're squeezing the last--how
many have we got left in the Moderator [INDISTINCT]
can get the next [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: Four, four more.
>> HYNDMAN: Four more and four minutes, go.
>> BUTCHER: Go.
>> RHODE: Where in the source code can I find
the 4.1 lock screen, Google it.
>> HYNDMAN: Did you read all of it?
>> RHODE: I read also that the developer.android.com
documentation is part of AOSP.
I assume so, it's--I mean we put the AOSP
copyright in our sample code and stuff.
>> SUTTON: It is.
I'll put a link to the location in the notes.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, and I think the lock screens
is called the key guard, so if you grab codes
with key guard, I think it's the thing you're
looking for.
>> RHODE: Sounds right to me.
Plus one.
>> BUTCHER: Next question.
>> RHODE: Can I retrieve data from Google
Maps APIs so I can use it for my location
based service.
Yes, use the Google Maps API.
Developers.google.com/maps.
>> SUTTON: Next muffin.
>> RHODE: I have a device with only Ethernet
connection, how can I find if device is really
connected to the network.
Try to push some traffic through.
>> BUTCHER: Hit, [INDISTINCT] it will get
active in a minute.
Network [INDISTINCT] is connected.
Next.
>> SUTTON: Try to connect to Google's webpage.
>> BUTCHER: No, if it's connected it will
do that, right?
It's connected; it's like the blue, you know,
how your Wifi turns blue when there's really
bits flowing.
I'm pretty sure it's based on the same logic.
>> RHODE: And this just--sort of code features
prominently I believe in Reto blog article
about writing battery friendly apps.
So, yeah.
You can search for it on developer.android.com.
We got blog articles and Google IO talks that
all touch on this.
Is anybody aware on how Android handles Daylight
Savings Time changes?
It does, also...
>> HYNDMAN: Even if the code...
>> RHODE: Even if it, even if it didn't, I
mean generally speaking you want your device
to get it's time of day from either your phone
network or NTP, in with and in either of those
cases.
You know, their smart to know--smart enough
to know about Daylight Savings Time and when
it happens, then it--your device will notice
that it's out of sync and it will reset itself.
>> HYNDMAN: But they are also asking which
part of the source code deals with this, so
it looks like they want to get some, pull
something out and reuse maybe.
>> SUTTON: I think that's actually kind...
>> BUTCHER: Time is hard.
>> SUTTON: Yeah, I think that's actually handled
by a lot of the lower level Linux stuff that's
underneath Android.
>> HYNDMAN: I wouldn't be too surprised.
Java deals with a pretty...
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, maybe, no.
Java does it horribly.
Look at like [INDISTINCT] the time or something
like that perhaps.
>> BANES: Don't you share the time, it's massive.
>> RHODE: I seem to remember, in the run off
to Jelly Bean for a little while we actually
had a bug where the NTP fallback wasn't working
right.
>> HYNDMAN: Uh-hmm.
>> RHODE: So.
>> SUTTON: Android actually has a utility
class which re-implements and the getting
the number of milliseconds from the APK.
Because it's so unreliable incident past the
Java, so.
>> BUTCHER: Was that in system.get current
Millis or...
>> SUTTON: There's a--I can dig out the method
for this.
There's actually an Android version of system.get
current time in Millis which is used for key
events.
>> BUTCHER: Uh-hmm.
>> SUTTON: And you can pick that out and basically
it does the same thing but I'm guessing it's
there because there's some discrepancies about
how it gets reported through.
>> BUTCHER: It was interesting because I read
about the three or four different ways you
get the current time.
I think the most accurate one was someone
from the Kernel which is exposed at for a
native [INDISTINCT] think you can do.
[INDISTINCT] trying to get out.
>> HYNDMAN: And with that.
>> BUTCHER: Are we done?
>> HYNDMAN: I think we are done.
>> RHODE: That's it from the Moderator.
>> HYNDMAN: Tablets.
>> GAUNT: Tablets.
>> HYNDMAN: We were going to say tablets ten
times we didn't say enough the last time.
>> BUTCHER: Not enough time.
>> ELKRIEF: Even to, speaking to.
>> HYNDMAN: Damn it.
>> BUTCHER: Any last minute questions from
the Hang Out?
>> ELKRIEF: Yeah, just a little question about
the subscription and trial version periods.
>> HYNDMAN: Yes.
>> ELKRIEF: If I want to do and app 12 for
a trial period, but it's not--this is basically
a subscription app.
Say you want to do like a snooze button or
a silent button widget and instead of doing
it into a paid app or something like that,
can I operate on a trial version with some
sort of subscription?
>> HYNDMAN: Do you have anything--if you're
not using subscriptions, the only option would
be to not [INDISTINCT] and then pop up a dialogue
after 30 days or however long you want to
the free period to be.
Subscription is the only part of Google Play
that offers a free trial period for you.
And for that free trial, you have to sign
up to the subscription, you have to have the
valid kind of details in place, and at the
first billing cycle is completed and starts
charging you.
>> ELKRIEF: Uh-hmm.
>> HYNDMAN: So, yeah...
>> BUTCHER: It's cool.
All right.
I think that's all we had time...
>> ELKRIEF: Do you want to see more Androids
on my offices?
>> SUTTON: [INDISTINCT] after that.
>> ELKRIEF: Will close up with a tour of the
Google office.
>> BUTCHER: Hey, how about that?
>> ELKRIEF: Oh, and over there we have...
>> HYNDMAN: Well, there's an Apple.
What's that [INDISTINCT]
>> ELKRIEF: No, yeah, it's--at the bathing
room, you know, everybody is fighting so;
we're doing it, so.
>> BUTCHER: Have fun.
>> HYNDMAN: Cool, we just did.
Thank you very much for joining us today.
We will be back again next week.
>> ELKRIEF: Will be back.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, so hopefully you'll maybe
see some people watching in Défis, Berlin
this weekend.
Matt you're going to be in Paris tomorrow,
you'll speaking to the wonderful [INDISTINCT].
>> GAUNT: Paris on Friday, yeah.
Berlin on Saturday.
>> BUTCHER: Don't forget there are some great
shows on Friday.
There's the App Clinic and the Friday Games
Review and join us next Tuesday Center Line
Action or see you all next week, next Wednesday
hopefully for more Office Hours.
>> SUTTON: And as Ray turns one [INDISTINCT]
three and everything that's going on [INDISTINCT]
in the way.
I swear in last week he was offering badges.
>> BUTCHER: Bye.
>> HYNDMAN: Bye.
>> Bye